I think peace is more like happiness
having peace in your heart you're very
beautiful grandma I know I know don't
tell it to everybody though
[Music]
you don't have to be beautiful in the
face you can be beautiful in character
everybody is entitled dad happiness and
the people don't make them happy one
thing that you should all do this if you
just do things that you feel it's gonna
make you happy and sometimes you'd be
lucky enough what happens sometimes you
want oh yes I wish I had some things
differently
everything you do wrong you have to some
and no matters up for you if you use so
say someone you got there so some see
and follow him but round them coming up
gonna follow neck round okay help then
that roll ain't none coming up yes so
good
the only sanctifying Island in a
marriage is what the two people bring to
it it's not by somebody saying words she
goes away I go mine I really believe in
communication is so essential and that
you need to work out many different
areas before you get married I think you
need to talk about money matters I think
you need to talk about child-rearing
I think religious important I think sex
takes care of itself pretty much at
least initially be honest
save your money you can love each other
don't be envious
be jealous forgive and you'll be
forgiven and if you don't forgive you
won't be forgiven just playing is that
[Music]
hey my neighbors don't do my neighbors
are sweet to me but nobody can carry
Mary Carter but Mary corridors well
whatever you could cuff me or anything
wherever you could swim in Wrigley now
he was to swim I do I'm fine thank you
he doesn't smoke a lot there doesn't he
it does hmm gets on your nerves